let's [__] something up
oh you know what hold on a sec hello Brainiac is
it happening now great you will have Luther ASAP
blue they're all you have
to do is come and get him
what the hell was that flash is alive and he has
Luther one damn thing at a time that artillery is
going to wreak havoc on our front line if there's
a snowball's chance in hell you can destroy it
I expect you to no matter the cost are we clear
yeah where the snowball time to light them all up
for my way
all my big guys let's dance
oh
that's gonna leave a mark yeah focus on fire
on this tank why do we never get reinforcements
watch your mate
love explosions
foreign
just call me the Pinball Wizard
[Music]
foreign
taking down the flash thing go
she's still in play let me get
out of my way I have work to do
well hey there sleepyhead we've
got an interrogation to get back to
[Music]
walk away until these guys everything
you know you think they can stop us
pathetic pathetic at least I'm not a
big hero turn stooge for a space man
okay boomerang you want to see what
a real hero can do I'll show you
foreign how do I stop this
tell me how
you have to kill us Diana
we have to die to save the world
foreign